قبل شهر تقريبا شهد الدور السينما
السعوديه تدشين الفيلم الكوميديا السعودي
ستار الذين لا يزال حتى الان يتصدر شباك
التذاكر في السينما السعوديه الفيلم من
بطوله ابراهيم الحجاج وعبد العزيز الشهري
ابراهيم خير الله وغيرهم من النجوم
نتابع مع زميل العنود العبدلي ابرز
الارقام حتى الان التي حققها الفيلم
ناسي في السعوديه الفيلم يواصلوا صداره
شباك التذاكر طوال 30 يوما حيث تم تفسير
العروض في التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر
الماضي 20 22 عدده التذاكر المبيعه في دور
السينما مشاهدينا الفيلم الكوميدي ستار
تجاوز
450,000 تذكره من معدله يتجاوز 13 الفتره
يوميا ويجعله اكثر الافلام السعوديه
مشاهده في دور السينما تاريخيا تراه
الفيلم السعودي ولد ملكه
واحده 150,000 تذكره ثم فيلم شمس المعارف
ب 24 الف تذكره مبيعه مشاهدينا ماذا عن
العوائد التي حققها في المخطار هل هي اكبر
في تاريخ السينما السعوديه من خلال عدد
التذاكر فان متوسطه العوائد التقريبي
يتجاوز 20 مليون ريال خلال شهر واحد فقط
ذلك وفقا للرئيس التنفيذي لشركه افلام
الشميسي المنتجه للفيلم ابراهيم الخير
الله
عاد هنا الاوبن كابتشر ضروري يكون يفتح
النفس المفتوحه على الصاله
انضم لنا في الاستوديو الممثل والمنتج
السينمائي ابراهيم الخير الله ابراهيم
حياك الله اول شيء الله يحييك يا اهلا
وسهلا
والف الف مبروك على نجاح الفيلم الارقام
اللي تاكد هذا النجاح اتكلم عنها 20 مليون
ريال اااه ونتكلم عن اكثر من 450 الف
تذكره احنا هذه ارقامنا التقديريه انتم
اللي عندكم الارقام الحقيقيه لكن انا ابغى
اعرف شلون وصلتوا الى هذا الرقم
لما عدت او همم السينما السعوديه وافتتاح
الصلاه كان في عده افلام سعوديه موجوده
يمكن ثمانيه همم كل وقت المعرفه ويمكن صحح
لي
واغلبها يمكن كانت كوميديه التسويق جيد
لكن اغلبها كمان فشل يمكن بعضها حتى ما
استمر في الصلاه وفي العارضه اكثر ستار
غير المعادله تمام
الله بالخير جميعا من الرياض طلعه حلوه
بعد
ستار احنا لما بدانا فيه بدينا في التلفاز
اصلا كان عندنا زي ما انت عارف خط اوردي
ماشيين فيه افلام لتلفاز فقررنا نفتح ارم
جديد في التلفاز والدراع جديده في التلفاز
متخصصه في افلام شباك التذاكر واسميناها
افلام الشميسي اهل الرياض
ااا السنوات اللي فاتت في البدايه
المتصدرين الثلاثه افلام عربيه مصريه
يعجب الجمهور اللي موجود وانت ما تكتفي بس
انك تاخذ الجمهور ايش يعجبه لازم تضيف
عليها ايش بهاراتنا وكشنتنا وشغلاتنا
وكبساتنا وامورنا على اساس توصل لفيلم
يشبه للي بيقعد على الكرسي بيدفع فلوس
عشان يقعد على الكرسي فهمم من الدروس
الافلام المصريه استفدنا من دروس
الافلام
تتصور ان الافلام
هو شغله هو اسطوري اصلا بنى عالم ثاني
يعني غير العالم لهذا ولكن سالتني عن
الصوص والخلطه هي ما يعجب ويكون قريب لكل
عائله لكل فرد لكل وحرصنا فيه يعجب
الجمهور السعودي شفتم انت تقول انا اخذت
او درست لحالك بالتالي وش النتيجه اللي
وصلت لها في الجمهور السعودي او الجمهور
السينما السعوديه يحبون الكوميدي يحبون
الاكشن فخلطنا بين الكوميدي والاكشن طبعا
في ستار كان فيه الكوميدي طاغي على الاكشن
بس الاكشن موجود واخترنا مظل اللي هي مظله
المصارعه لانها يعني قاعده تشتغل يعني
ممكن في العالم كله مو مره بس هنا شفنا
كراون جول مع الترفيه مثلا حضور خرافي
شفنا الناس لسه مهتمه بهذا الشيء واحنا
نذكر يعني لعبه المراكشي في الصاله
انتم عملتوا خلطه عجيبه وخلطه الدماء يعني
انت جبت كميه كوميديا جبتو كمان جريمه
قتال عوالم سفليه بس خليني اقول لك مثلا
بعد النقاد مثلا قالوا انتم عملتوا حاجه
واضفتم فيها النكهه السعودي لكن الفكره
اصلا القالب قالب معروف حلو هذا اللي
موجود فيه هوليود هذا الموجود في بوليود
هم كلما دروس اساس القصه ما نعرف مثلا هذه
المصارعه اللي بتجيء تحت همم
لكن
هذا ترى كل ما غير زيت اول اطالع يقول من
يروح ابو علي
اشياء لما تقولها الجمهور ايه والله صدق
والله يمكن في شيء في الحفره تحت هو والله
صدق والله في شيء ثاني غير كده اللي
استفدت منا من الافلام العربيه هي همم انت
ما تمتعه بس بصريا امتعه بعد سمعيا عشان
كذا في البوم نزل عليه
موجود
مثلا على سبيل المثال اللي رفع اكثر
انها عندها الغزاله رايقه كلنا نعرف
الغزاله ترى هذه اغنيه فيلم
قصه على ذلك في امريكا في نفس الشيء
المركز الخامس
اكتشاف الجديد اللي عملته شاد الجفاري
كمان همم لكن خليني اسالك عن الاضافه اللي
قدمتها اثناء ورشي الكتابه انتم بايمن
والتوتر وايمن اسم معروف يعني مجال التالي
في الكوميديا من العمل ليش استعنتوا فيه
انا اقول لك ليش احنا اكثر شيء سويناه
شورت فيلم قبل هذا الفيلم تحديدا انا يعني
شخصيا في بروجكت هذا كامل فانا ابغى اخاف
يعني خوف كبير اني في ساعه و45 لا يطيح
الايقاع لا يطيح الايقاع لا هذا اهم شيء
فمن وين انا باجيب المعلومه غير ان واحد
قد سوى عارف طيب ما شاء الله
ما يمل لازم الواحد في الشق الاول
في الفيلم
في هذا الجزء الاول لازم ما تتعدى دقائق
معينه اللي انت معطيني شيء يعلقني في
الجزء الثاني هي تجزا الفيلم قصه جابرز
الاول والثاني والثالث ما اطلع من الاول
الا معطيك شيء يعلقك تدخل في الثاني معطيك
شيء تدخل في الثالث
الين اسلمك سلام عليكم هذا التتر ابراهيم
الترافات والسقف في السينما السعوديه
ويمكن انا رجعت لواحد من النقاد والكتاب
همم في السينما وقال ستائر خل السينما
السعوديه والفيلم السعوديه قبل 16 شيء
وبعد 16 ثانيه اليوم مش تفكرون فيه يعني
بالنسبه للسينما في مشروعكم القادم او
المشروع الثاني ايه في افلام احنا احنا
نفكر بس في مشروعنا الثاني الحاله احنا
نفكر بس في ال- المشاريع السعوديه كلها
لان صراحه لازم تدخل السينما السعوديه تبي
تشوف التوب 5 لازم يكون في اقل شيء اثنين
ثلاثه
فيلم السعودي لازم يكون اقوى من الفيلم
اللي جاي من خارج السعوديه
واتمنى لكم التوفيق ابراهيم خير الله
الممثل المنتج السينمائي السعودي مباشر